WE HAVE BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD A
FEW TIMES THIS YEAR.
EACH TIME IT'S NOT EASY.
TONIGHT MARKS THE END OF AN ERA,
THE FINAL SHOW OF THE LONGEST
SERVING MEMBER OF THE GREATEST
[BLEEP] NEWS TEAM,
SAMANTHA BEE.
IT ALL STARTED BACK IN 2003 OT
THREE.
THE BUSH PRESIDENCY WAS ENTERING
ITS TERRIBLE TWOs.
THE IRAQ WAR WAS JUST STARTING.
SO WE NEEDED A CORRESPONDENT, WE
LOOKED IN THE USUAL PLACES,
YOUR LIQUOR STORES, YOUR BETTING
PARLORS, YOUR METHADONE CLINICS,
AND OBVIOUSLY GOOGLE MAPS WAS
IN ITS NASCENT STAGES,
AND WE TOOK A WRONG TURN,
WE ENDED UP IN CANADA.
(LAUGHTER)
AND WE FOUND THIS, THIS, THIS
JUST DELIGHTFUL, INCREDIBLY
FUNNY, PERSON, SAM BEE.
SO WE HID HER IN THE TRUNK AND
RACED BACK OVER THE BORDER
PURSUED BY MOUNTIES.
CANADA HAD NO IDEA WHAT IT WAS
LOSING.
>> HAVE YOU HAD A HOT CARL SINCE
YOU'VE BEEN HERE?
>> I HAVE NOT. I JUST,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S SO MUCH
TO DO, I HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO
DO EVERYTHING YET.
>> I COULD TOTALLY SEE IF LONG
ISLAND SECEDED AS ITS OWN STATE.
>>WE'RE A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
GROUP OF PEOPLE.
>> WHAT STATE COULD YOU BEAT UP?
>> IRELAND.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT COUNTS.
>> OH, STATES, I'M SORRY.
>> OTHER STATES.
>> I FEEL LIKE A RETARD NOW.
>> OTHER STATES NOT IN EUROPE.
>> STATEN ISLAND.
>> OTHER STATES.
>> CANADA?
>> CANADA? OKAY.
>> NONE OF THESE TOOLS ARE
STERILE.
>> OKAY, WELL NEITHER IS THIS.
SO LET'S GO.  GET STARTED.
CAN I CALL YOU
BACK? MY MOM IS IN MY ROOM,
AND SHE WANTS TO TALK TO ME
ABOUT SOMETHING!
I'M SAMANTHA BEE AND I WATCH
THE FIVE!
IT'S THE TALE OF A WINSOME
BLONDE INGENUE, DANA PARINO.
THERE'S GOT TO BE A CATCH!
COULD YOU MAKE IT SNAPPY?
I'VE GOT PLACES TO BE. SERIOUSLY
OKAY, DRIPPING WET BALLS.
IGNORE THIS.
BABY'S ON FIRE AGAIN. DAMN IT.
YOU TWO TIMING MONSTER -- AHHH!
I'M THE ONE GETTING  FLOWN OUT
OF THIS (BLEEP) POOL!
ONE PILL MAKES YOU LARGER AND --
LET IT RING!
>> WELL I THINK A LOT OF THE
TIME IT FEELS LIKE A
THANKLESS JOB.
PEOPLE THINK OUR DAY ENDS AT
3:00 AND THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
WE FEEL UNAPPRECIATED.
>> GIVES MEN BASICALLY INSTANT
ERECTIONS.
TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF DOING.
>> OH BOY, OKAY, OKAY.
HAVE YOU HAD YOUR PICTURE TAKEN
WITH A BLACK PERSON YET?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK SO, BUT I
WOULDN'T MIND DOING IT.
>> THAT'S SOMETHING YOU WOULD BE
WILLING TO TRY?
>> WHY, CERTAINLY.
>> THERE'S PLENTY OF THEM.
>> I KNOW.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY OF THEM IN
MONTANA?
>> WE DON'T, YOU KNOW. WE DON'T
HAVE ANY.
IN FACT, OUR KIDS WERE PRETTY
OLD BEFORE THEY SAW ONE.
>> Jon: HERE'S A LITTLE
SOMETHING, SOME DAILY SHOW
TRIVIA, OF ALL OF OUR
CORRESPONDENTS SAM IS ONLY
THE THIRD CORRESPONDENT
TO EVER GET HER
FACE STUCK IN A PENIS PUMP.
BUT WHILE SHE COULD ALWAYS DO
THE SILLY, THE SAM PIECES THAT
I LOVED THE BEST ARE THE ONES
CLOSEST TO HER HEART.
>> SARAH PALIN TOOK THE STAGE
AND SILENCED HER CRITICS.
BUT THERE'S ONE ISSUE FOR WHICH
SHE'S STILL BEING
UNFAIRLY ATTACKED.
>> IT'S VERY INAPPROPRIATE
THAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE SEIZED
ON THE ISSUE OF BRISTOL'S
PREGNANCY.
>> I THINK IT'S A FAMILY ISSUE.
>> YOU KNOW, SHE'S GOING TO HAVE
THE BABY,
SHE'S GOING TO GET MARRIED..
>> SHE SAID NO, IT'S A HUMAN
BEING.
>> SHE MADE THE -- I'M SORRY,
WHAT IS THE DECISION --
THE DECISION -- THERE'S ANOTHER
WORD I'M LOOKING FOR.
I THINK IT RHYMES WITH VOICE.
EVERY FAMILY AND EVERY WOMAN
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO --
I'M SORRY, WHAT'S THE WORD I'M
LOOKING FOR?
IT'S HER FAMILY, IT'S HER --
GOD, WHAT IS THE WORD?
WHAT IS THE WORD
I'M LOOKING FOR?
IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU HAVE A LOT
OF OPTIONS, AND YOU HAVE TO
SELECT ONE. WHAT'S THE WORD
I'M LOOKING FOR?
WHAT IS THE WORD I'M LOOKING
FOR?
>> ADOPTION IS ONE.
>> NO, THERE'S A SPECIFIC WORD
I'M LOOKING FOR.
>> YES, BUT I DON'T THINK THE --
I DON'T THINK THAT THE
DECISION -- I THINK IT SHOULD
BE -- NOT -- I THINK THAT THE
FAMILY DECISION WOULD BECOME --
THAT'S HOW -- YES.
OKAY.
>> A DIFFERENT CHOICE?
CHOICE!
YES!
EXACTLY!
EVERY FAMILY, EVERY PERSON
SHOULD HAVE THE CHOICE TO DECIDE
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEM!
>> THERE MAY SEE A 10-YEAR-OLD
OUT THERE PICKING TOBACCO BUT
YOU WON'T SEE HIM THERE ALL DAY.
>> I WORK 12 HOURS A DAY IN THE
TOBACCO FARM.
>> OR SOMETIMES A LITTLBE BIT
LONGER.
>> OKAY, WOW. YOU'RE MAKING IT
VERY HARD FOR ME
TO IRONICALLY SUPPORT
CHILD TOBACCO LABOR.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THAT HE WANTS
US TO TALK ABOUT RACE.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT RACE!
YOU GO FIRST.
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE GREAT IF
YOU STARTED OFF.
>> I DON'T THINK IT WOULD BE
GREAT AT ALL.
>> IF YOU'RE SCARED, SAY YOU'RE
SCARED.
(LAUGHTER)
>> WHY WOULD I BE SCARED? NO!
I'M NOT AT ALL.
I'M JUST INCREDIBLY
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> I KNOW THE PERCENTAGE IS SO
SMALL, SO SMALL OF A PERSON
BECOMING PREGNANT FROM A RAPE
THAT I JUST DON'T EVEN KNOW IF
THAT'S EVEN IN THE EQUATION
BECAUSE THEY SAY THAT PERCENTAGE
IS JUST, LIKE, ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE.
NOT IMPOSSIBLE BUT CLOSE, AND
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME CASES.
>> YEAH, PROBABLY ABOUT 32,000 A
YEAR.
>> IS IT 32? OKAY.
>> THOUSAND.
>> YEAH, OKAY.
>> 32,000.
>> WOMEN IN COMBAT POSITIONS ARE
A THREAT TO MILITARY COHESION.
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT MEN CAN
ACTUALLY BOND WITH WOMEN.
MEN JOIN THE INFANTRY BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO FIGHT.
>> SORRY, EXCUSE ME FOR ONE
SECOND.
OKAY. OKAY, THAT'S MUCH BETTER.
SORRY.
>> GIRLS BECOME WOMEN BY GETTING
OLDER.
BOYS BECOME MEN BY ACCOMPLISHING
SOMETHING, BY PROVING SOMETHING.
>> OKAY.
HAVE YOU EVER ACTUALLY MET A
WOMAN BEFORE?
>> SEVERAL.
>> UM...
A WOMAN WHO DID NOT WANT TO
STRANGLE YOU?
>> THE REVERSE HAPPENS AS WELL,
WHERE HOMOSEXUALS GO OUT AND
FIND STRAIGHTS TO BEAT UP.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH.
>> ARE YOU SURE ABOUT THAT?
HEY!
WATCH OUT!
I'VE GOT A CHRISTIAN!
GUYS! DAMN IT!
IT'S LIKE YOU CAN'T EVEN GO ON
THE RADIO ANYMORE AND CONDEMN A
WHOLE SUBSET OF PEOPLE TO HELL
WITHOUT GETTING SOME BLOWBACK.
>> WHEN YOU PUT IT THAT WAY IT
DOES SOUND RATHER ARROGANT,
MYOPIC, NARROW-MINDED AND
BIGOTED.
>> GOOD, THEN I'VE DONE MY JOB.
>> Jon: PLEASE WELCOME OUR
SENIOR, SENIOR CORRESPONDENT
CORRESPONDENT SAMANTHA BEE!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)